let's get back to the phones and by
phones i don't really mean phones i mean
discord because we use discord now and
we are going to hear from some people uh
just as a reminder to everybody who's
waiting in the waiting lobby if you have
a nickname
if you have you know some kind of joke
or whatever the case may be i will not
be going to you so it's totally fine to
have your nickname or whatever i see
people with all sorts of nicknames uh
you're just your name has to be in the
format of your name and where you're
calling from in order to be eligible to
get on with me today along those lines
let's go to sam from minnesota sam thank
you for
sticking to the rules with your nickname
oh yeah how's my volume your volume's
pretty pretty okay yeah all right so uh
i guess one
just a minnesota question uh we've we've
uh been on top of the
voting turnout for quite a while i think
the last
five six seven no i think maine beat us
back in 2010 anyway so we have had the
best turnout do you think that'll
if turnout continues to skyrocket do you
think we'll stay on top or do you think
we might lose out to somebody you know
that's a very interesting question uh
you know i didn't know
but you were right it looks like the top
turnout in the u.s
in
2022 now what does this include i guess
this must be primaries it's minnesota
new jersey
and oregon is that does that sound right
to you the top turnout states very very
interesting um i didn't know new jersey
was so high the last general in 2020 uh
maine was second place but new jersey
yeah new jersey would be really
skyrocketing if they were number two
because they were
you know what i'm seeing i'm seeing new
jersey's number one at 85 percent and
minnesota's number two at 83 percent can
you believe it 80
wow if new jersey's in the 80s that's
pretty crazy yeah they must have some
really determined primary goers yeah so
uh
bait so now that i have the data in
front of me what was your question
or just uh in the general do you think
minnesota will stay on top or do you
think it's gonna be in jew jersey
i have no idea i mean listen i don't
know the dynamics of the
you've got like primary and in general i
think that all of these states are going
to be high um
part of it is the relationship between
what is the process to register to vote
versus
how likely are you to go and vote so
there's this i my instinct is there's
this kind of reverse
mechanism where
if it's harder to register to vote which
i'm against right i think it should be
really easy to register but if it's
harder to register
your turnout as a share of registered
voters might end up being higher because
there's sort of like more obstacles to
get registered so you're probably more
enthusiastic about voting so i don't
know enough about voter registration
process in new jersey minnesota
mississippi oregon which are the top
four turnout states i think we're just
basically guessing and we have to wait
and see
yeah i i think um i'm not so sure about
automatic registration but like same day
registration where you walk in to vote
and you're like oh i'm not registered
well let me just register then yeah it's
it's incomprehensible to me that anybody
doesn't do that minnesota does and we've
done it since the 70s and right
beautiful
well congratulations to minnesota for
voting and we'll see what things look
like in the fall
yeah thanks all right thank you for the
call very much appreciate it